[Musique]
à 19 ans j'ai été rapatrié vous devez
sûrement vous demandez de quoi je parle
j'étais à la fac
de roy
et
bien sûr les parents jouent un rôle
précisément mon père il voulait que je
fasse ce économie gestion
bien sûr j'avais pas envie de faire
économie gestion j'étais censé faire des
études de mode c'est ce que j'avais
envie de faire depuis douze ans j'avais
envie de m'inscrire dans une école de
mode ont
donc on m'a vendu l'illusion qu'à la fin
qu'après mon bac j'allais bien sûr conçu
cette étude mais ça n'a pas été le cas
ok pas de ce si j'obtiens mon bac
direction rouen donc j'étais à evreux en
normandie direction roi et j'arrive
là-bas je me rends compte que évidemment
bien sûr c'est parce que je voulais
faire je m'ennuyais à la fac parce qu'il
ya pas de deux
d'interaction vraiment vous êtes là
le prof est là il fait son cours que
vous avez compris ou non vous partez je
sais pas si d'autres personnes ont eu
cette expérience mais c'est l'expérience
que j'ai eue de la fac donc j'abandonne
rebelles à l'époque encore plus que je
ne le suis maintenant j'abandonne
et je crois qu'on devrait en avril ou
mai je décide d'arrêter la fac et puis
daddy mat
donc voilà
c'est exactement le genre de tête qui
l'aurait fait alors juste après ça je
rentre en vacances à cotonou avec la
tête rasée à l'ariana comme vous pouvez
le voir là j'avais raté une première
fois puis après j'ai décidé de tout
raser pour choquer encore plus non je
rigole c'est juste que j'ai toujours été
attiré par tout ce qui est artistique
créatif et depuis que je suis petit
temps je faisais toujours je demandais
toujours aux coiffeuses de me rajouter
quelques mèches blondes mais c'était mal
interprétés on disait elle est folle
mais l'agité mais qu'est-ce qui est là
mais j'étais juste attirer en fait je
pense que ça a été aussi guidé par ma
mère parce que ma mère a toujours eu les
cheveux courts blonds je me suis dit
quand je serai grande je veux ressembler
à cette femme
cette femme qui m'a élevé éduqués qui
est belle forte
et donc voilà
voilà donc que riri favori d'avis
j'arrive à cotonou vous imaginez
je me suis dit mon père ça peut passer
la coiffure va falloir que je trouve une
solution j'ai mis un foulard je suis
allé le voir et dès que j'arrive
il avait le visage serré
donc comme on dit qu'ils avaient la mine
renfrognée et il me dit je pense que je
ne sais pas ce que tu as sur la tête je
suis au courant donc maisons ont déjà
passé le message tu as fait c'est très
certainement la première question qui me
posent
ils me demandent si je suis punk chez
boutique chef punk qu'est ce qui se
passe mais on va tout voler dans le
métro qu'est ce qui se passe et moi
intérieurement j'avais envie de rigoler
mais je devais rester sérieuse parce que
je savais que j'étais toujours naomi est
de toute façon j'étais habitué à ce
qu'on me juge pour mon apparence je
portais pas forcément des choses
extravagantes je portais juste des
couleurs flashy je faisais des coiffures
de couleurs est-ce que c'est censé être
un problème pour moi juge-t-on à
l'apparence pas seulement au bénin en
afrique peut-être partout dans le monde
nouvelles des siècles qui m'annonce
qu'il a cogité quelques jours après je
vais le voir
il me dit tu ne repart plus en france tu
restes ici avec moi nous sommes en
[Musique]
quelle année 2011 2012 oui j'avais 19
ans donc je reste mais rêve s'écroule ma
vie est chamboulée je me demande qu'est
ce que je vais bien pouvoir fait en fait
le bénin c'est mon pays je suis fier d'y
amener je suis fier d'y être mais j'ai
pas fini moi j'avais déjà commencé à
postuler j'avais des stars âge j'avais
trouvé des opportunités en fait donc là
je suis perdu je suis très en colère
je ne parle pas mon père pendant
peut-être trois mois et la saab c'est
son caractère aussi mais malgré ça je
tiens tête je suis rebelles
et donc qu'est ce qui se passe après
après réflexion bien sûr je me dis j'ai
pas envie forcément de me brouiller avec
mon père c'est mon père après tout ça ne
me coûte rien d'essayer il me dit et
c'est dans dix ans tu vas me remercier
sûr de lui
voilà j'essaye
et ma condition à moi c'est que vous
savez mon père est journaliste et il
voulait bien sûr que je devienne
journalistes et donc je travaille avec
lui ma condition à moi même si depuis
que j'étais petit j'allais à la radio et
que je m'entraînais à faire des pauses
de voix etc j'étais un peu baigné dans
le métier j'avais quand même mes propres
et donc j'étais prête à aider mon père
mais j'avais mon propre chemin que
j'avais envie de tracer
donc
donc voilà ma condition c'était que je
finisse mes études je ne voulais pas
être catalogué comme la fidh deux parce
que mon père a réussi tant mieux pour
lui mais je suis naomi je suis naomi
soumanou je ne veux pas vivre dans
l'ombre de mon père
à yann moix sarov a avant tout me faut
ma seule arme par le faut
vous savez
hb qui m'anime quand je parle de ça
parce que
donc je reste ici je fais mes études à
l'esma donc institut supérieur des
métiers de l'audiovisuel et ça se passe
bien bien sûr on m'avait déjà collé une
étiquette c'est la fille de hockey pas
de ceci je reste dans mon coin et j'ai
l'impression que au bénin on aime bien
montrer que ces mêmes les haies les
dirigeants qu'on a comme on appelle ça
ici qui en classe on dit un jour à voile
à l'affût de ce journaliste et ça m'a
énervé parce que je voulais me faire
tout petit ça n'a pas marché c'est pas
grave ça s'est bien passé je retiens que
du positif de cette expérience comme
quoi on peut revenir en afrique faire de
très bonnes études il y avait de très
bons profs en tout cas je garde que le
positif malgré les les étiquettes qu'on
a pu me coller mon diplôme obtenu haut
la main mention très bien je vais voir
mon père une faveur laisse-moi les en
angleterre il réfléchit je pense qu'il
faudrait pas vraiment me refuser ça
parce que je venais de lui faire plaisir
et donc je pars pour l'angleterre
et donc pour perfectionner mon anglais
voilà et là-bas j'arrive je suis dans
une famille d'accueil british parce que
c'était le seul moyen pour moi de
d'être vraiment inséré
dans le dans la langue voilà parce que
je suis arrivé je me disais je comprends
anglais parce que je regardais des films
américains j'ai parlé mon petit anglais
je me disais qu'en fait je vais gérer
mais j'arrive je ne comprends que dalle
les gens me parlent jeudi macaigne web
it with
your friends
ils sont là mais vous êtes française
ayew french parce que dès qu'ils
entendent un accent bon on comprend pas
trop on est français je dis oui on
french speak french et donc petit à
petit parce qu'ils partent très vite
même les anglais entre eux ils ne se
comprennent pas il ya plusieurs villes
et je peux vous dire par exemple contre
manchester et je sais pas moi landon ils
vont pas forcément se comprendre les
actions varie donc voilà
j'obtiens job parce que je tiens
pratiquer la langue est un job rémunéré
et mon père comment savoir que celle là
elle est pas parti pour six mois je
reste plus à chaque fois qu'ils me dit
de rentrer je trouve une opportunité de
rester et je me souviens un jour il m'a
dit 'il est temps que tu rentres je
pense que tu as atteint un niveau le
reste va venir avec la pratique
et je lui dis non il faut que je passe
un examen je vais pas revenir quand même
voilà elle allait faire des cours
d'anglais et puis c'est tout il faut que
je passe en examen un certificat quand
même donc je m'inscris à cambridge
university
et j'obtiens le certificat de cambridge
après ça donc j'ai obtient deux autres
job donc un dans une radio communautaire
de
reading ça une ville en angleterre donc
j'y allais une fois par semaine et
j'animais un show avec un africain puis
j'avais un autre job aussi dans une
charité et puis voilà donc après les six
mois passés dans la première famille
d'accueil c'est eux me voilà au bout là
donc eux c'est les wade et je suis
arrivé on m'avait parlé particulièrement
de la nourriture anglaise
la nourriture anglaise était essentielle
10 christique pas bon du tout les
anglais savent pas pris part et c'est
pas la peine à moins qu'ils ne soient
mis en musique pauvre en terme à
melvin coux donc je suis bien tombé ils
me font découvrir des plats sans pareil
tobin euros
je sais plus trop bon je sais qu'il ya
des gens qui ont fait l'angleterre dans
la talent qui fera peut-être de quoi je
parle et donc ça s'est super bien passé
et je pense que c'était une très bonne
expérience de venir où personne ne parle
français en fait vous n'avez pas le
choix vous êtes obligé de vous adapter
aux
la culture de la famille êtes obligés on
mangeait à 17 heures du 7 18 heures
c'est le repas en fait ces deux
nouvelles règles tu t'adaptes tu es venu
pour apprendre tu t'adaptes super bien
passé après je suis allé dans une autre
famille pour six autres mois mais j'ai
pas pu retrouver la photo ce sera pour
une prochaine fois après ça donc je
finis je rentre finalement malgré moi
parce que l'angleterre c'était ma easing
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait tout
ce qu'on disait chez moi bon ça c'est
pour c'est pas tout le monde bien sûr
j'ai un entourage dieu merci j'ai des
membres de mon entourage qui ont
toujours su que bon j'aimais bien les
couleurs et tous qui me soutenaient donc
qui ne trouvait pas ça bizarre j'arrive
en angleterre je me dis je ne suis rien
parce que d'un saut match - dr je me
suis retrouvé dans un monde où je me je
me sentais année en fait je me suis
retrouvé quelque part où les gens
étaient dans une autre dimension je me
suis dit au moins un big night date j'ai
encore beaucoup de choses à apprendre
mais qu'est-ce qu'on me raconte en fait
je suis là où je dois être donc vous
n'avez pas vraiment envie d'entrer mais
au final il faut retourner au pays je
reviens je fais une petite formation de
six mois intensive tous les matins tous
les soirs je fais quatre enregistrements
de d'édition de journal on simule le
matin est pareil l'après-midi en anglais
parce qu'il faut quand même montré que
tu allais en angleterre faut faut
montrer qu'on ap ap pour rien donc je
commence le journal à la télé au bénin
en anglais et donc ça se passe bien et
six mois après je suis life donc voilà
ça c'est un extrait d'une interview avec
ian mahimi son basketteur béninois qui
qui était dans la nba voilà pour vous
montrer ait ring sans meeting
devastating comment j'ai je me suis
servi de ce qui m'avait marqué pour en
ressortir quelque chose de positif en
fait et gt ça n'allait pas du tout j'ai
maigri je te dis presque et
voilà je je je me sentais pas vraiment
bien en fait parce que je me sentais
fort c'est de faire quelque chose que je
n'avais pas forcément envie de faire
peut-être que si on m'avait parlé on
m'avait pris la main oui faut que tu
rentres je me serais peut-être décider
mais je déteste qu'on me dise quoi faire
jeter ça mais pourtant je l'ait fait
malgré tout je remercie mes parents qui
m'ont donné une très bonne éducation je
ne suis pas parfaite mais je remercie
aussi mon père même s'il m'a forcé la
main aujourd'hui je suis breton je suis
reconnaissante d'être journaliste je
suis reconnaissante d'avoir obtenu un
diplôme et d'être ici devant vous de
présenter les infos de vous
de vous dire un peu ce qui se passe dans
le monde de vous informer de participer
à l'éducation de la population oui je
suis contente je ne suis pas satisfaite
ce dont je voulais parler aujourd'hui
principalement puisque nous sommes dans
le changement de mentalité par dawn
shift
c'est que je réalise ray tous mes rêves
je sais qu'on doit pas parler de
religion mais je crois en dieu j'ai la
foi et je sais que grâce à lui je
réaliserai mes rêves tous mes rêves et
personne ne me dira
que je ne peux pas faire ce que je sais
que je peux faire
les femmes doivent se soutenir de nos
jours trop de femmes se rabaisse entre
elles si vous aussi par exemple il ya
une femme qui est sur les réseaux
sociaux qui est qui est insultée vous
allez remarquer en fait dans les
commentaires et c'est ce que je remarque
qui me fait mal au coeur que la plupart
du temps ce sont des femmes qui
l'insultent hausse et une ceci c'est une
cela et c'est non et ce nom un souci
d'autrui mène donc supporter klitschko
va de wade est chaude c'est frustrant et
moi j'essaye sur mes réseaux sociaux en
tout cas de pousser les gens de ma
communauté de ma petite communauté a et
surtout les femmes on me dit pourquoi tu
partout dans les femmes parce que je
pense que les femmes sont le moteur les
femmes sont les maires de la nation sans
femmes il n'y aurait pas d'homme pour
moi pas que je néglige la place des
hommes merci aux hommes n'existent est
bien sûr mais nous devons revendiquer
nos places nous devons nous affirmer
nous imposer un peu plus nous devons
changer les choses travailler ensemble
we need to work together to church
frings
et n'est jamais trop tard pour réaliser
vos rêves on ne vit qu'une fois alors
toi femme qui me regardent jeune fille
hugh laurie gobeil queen nous sommes des
diamants nous avons été créés
pour illuminer la vie des hommes
et je pense que si on travaillait à
avoir notre différence
comme des
pas comme des points faibles si je peux
dire ça comme ça mais comme des
avantages des atouts que l'on peut
mettre ensemble afin de s'unir et créer
quelque chose de différent je pense
qu'on pourrait changer beaucoup de
choses fille d'autres femmes l'ont fait
angélique kidjo oprah winfrey rosa parks
beyoncé et je reviens quelques secondes
sur beyoncé parce qu'à chaque fois que
je la cite comme un exemple de réussite
féminin on dit mais de quoi tu parles
beyoncé c'est ça une chanteuse c'est une
danseuse mais bien le sais pour avoir
regardé cette vidéo du début elle a
commencé elle était toute petite
personne ne croyait en est là par ses
parents bien sûr et ça c'est une chance
elle s'est vue
se refuser beaucoup d'entrées on lui a
claqué beaucoup de fois la porte mais où
est ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui elle est
déterminée c'est une femme noire et je
pense qu'elle fait rêver beaucoup de
femmes noires et autres papas seulement
noir donc je pense que c'est un exemple
de réussite féminin pourquoi pas moi à
10h30 au stade you and you we deserve to
be lost en asie where we can do it
rouillac et bogho of the rings
je rêve d'un pays d'une afrique
d'amande ou les femmes auraient plus de
pouvoir dans les instances de décision
et au fond c'est nous qui détenons le
pouvoir et on n'a pas besoin de
revendiquer la place que nous avons déjà
nous avons la chance de donner la vie
nous éduquons nous bâtissons je pense
que nous devons changer de mentalité
c'est le sujet aujourd'hui et le
changement de mentalité devrait
s'appliquer dans notre génération et
dans les parents d'aujourd'hui que nous
sommes que nous serons nous devons
inculquer à nos enfants les bonnes
valeurs
we need to educate a working to be wild
in society we need to teach thème tout
sept violeurs
nous devons aussi leur apprendre
les encourager quand ils ont des rêves
il ya des biens des garçons qui veut
devenir footballeur on leur dit m qu'est
ce que tu veux faire il ya des rêves qui
se brisent trop souvent en afrique
surtout en afrique et il faut que ça
s'arrête et yang wei lee quane woman you
about ne laissez pas vos rêves être
étouffée
par des proches qui vous aiment que vous
aimez en retour ne laissez surtout pas
vos rêves s'étouffer
soyez vous même no matter what the coast
[Applaudissements]